well this is further reassurance for our
allies on the eastern flank of NATO for
the Baltic States and for Poland and
that is part of our policy of more
persistent presence on the eastern side
of NATO to respond to any further
Russian propagation and aggression large
numbers of troops a small number of
troops to start with do you accept that
NATO is on the back foot NATO and
Britain of course therefore have all
been outfoxed by the Russian well Russia
is making a very dangerous situation
sorry can I start again Russia is making
a very serious situation in Syria much
more dangerous and we'll be meeting
today to see what we can do to
de-escalate this crisis particularly in
terms of air safety will be calling on
Russia specifically to stop propping up
the Assad regime to use their influence
constructively to stop asad bombing his
own civilians and themselves to avoid
the use of unguided munitions in areas
that are not being controlled by ISIL
and will be also offering more support
to Syria's neighbors particularly Turkey
and Jordan basically you know that they
are not going to support they are not
going to stop supporting President Assad
don't they well if Russia wants to help
here the the single the single most
helpful thing they could do is use their
influence on our said to stop barrel
bombing his own civilians their children
his own cities and villages that's how
Russia could help now to resolve this
conflict you may deploy to the Baltics
what you'll actually be expecting them
to do there or they will be part of the
new tacit mission the new training
evaluation of capacity building mission
in the Baltic States and person that we
part of a more persistent pressure
presence by and NATO forces we
contributed last year to Baltic Air
Policing we'll be doing that again next
year and this is our policy of
persistent presence and aid for our
allies on the eastern flank of NATO in
response to knit to Russian aggression
and provocation
Thank You secretary said